today on the anime zone reveal fooly
cooly a totally normal anime about a
totally normal boy living a totally
normal city with a totally normal life
where nothing exciting ever happen
in the time I've been watching anime
I've seen my fair share of weird little
diffusing things I've seen cuddly little
teddy bears become terrorizing monsters
of death single lonely men running from
a group of hot desirable woman who
apparently want to [ __ ] him men who look
more like girls and actual girls and
well whatever the [ __ ] the Evangelion
ending was but after seeing the show I
can safely say that all those don't hold
a candle to the weirdness that is fooly
cooly but to be honest the Evangelion
ending can still go suck my dick Lee is
now in police by studio Gainax in the
year 2000 ironically the same studio
that produced Eve and getting on and is
one of the weirdest things I've ever
watched the anime itself comes with
three possible names you could roll it
fooly cooly if you want the English name
FL Co if you want the abbreviated name
or lastly you can call it if you're
Japanese or just want to sound like a
[ __ ] though it doesn't really matter
what you call it because the names make
no sense in the first place so given a
series a name like the results of LSD
The Adventures of horn boy mean a bunch
of pricks or what the [ __ ] is going on
would probably be more appropriate names
anyway let me try to explain the first
episode to you the anime starts off or
this boy called nail tune and Abba
explaining that everything in his life
is normal nothing exciting ever happens
he said with a giant [ __ ] line in the
middle of his city blowing out
mysterious smoke everywhere but whatever
this normal got it thing starts getting
quote-unquote weird when a random girl
appears norma skills in which he hits
him with her scooter she then starts
talking gibberish and revives him using
CPR and then proceeds to bash his head
in with her motorized bass guitar
causing a big bump to appear in his head
word and I could easily take the piss
out off but I'm not because I'm too
mature for that must resist [ __ ] Joe
must resist the cat Joe must with Nick
and Joe must resist [ __ ] Joe
later now to finds out to surprise at
the strange pink haired girl is actually
living in his house as a housekeeper the
Goofy's mutter then puts the go through
an intense questioning session to find
out the true identity of this mysterious
pink haired girl how are you
I'm just a wandering housekeeper tell me
the truth I'm an alien well [ __ ] that
was easy afterwards now - runs off to
talk to his brother's ex-girlfriend
before - robots spread out from the bump
his head and start fighting each other
for crazy girl appears again that
smashes one of them over the head with
her guitar again the episode ends with
the robot running some dough and now to
explaining that everything is normal and
nothing exciting ever happens because as
we all know being smashed in the head
are not dying
normal funny a crazy alien living any
houses are made normal having two giant
robots fighting to the death in front of
you
normal for anime looking like you have a
huge dick growing out of your head
normal ok sorry no more [ __ ] jokes
but in all honesty there's so much point
explained to the plot because it's so
rata Quran and they're trying to explain
a series we like trying to explain a
principle of relativity to a group of
monkeys
the story has no structure no set tone
no consistency there can be seen with a
totally dark edgy serious tone with the
main character in the rating as in her
thoughts the basic his role in life Adri
my achievements all his goals all is i
last about how the pacing of the whole
show goes the anime revolves around the
12-yard kid called Nauta who is at a
tender age where he thinks acting like
an adult is the equivalent of being an
all-around pessimistic dick to everyone
though to be fair doesn't really get the
best example from his father who seems
to think that being a well mature
sophisticated mature adult means acting
like [ __ ] apparently mommy me samejima
is a stranger at is the ex-girlfriend of
now his older brother who's moved to
America she seems to spend most of time
doing what every other typical seventeen
your rebel schoolgirl does she skips
classes she smokes cigarettes and she
touches little boys inappropriately wait
what
then comes the heart of this anime
Haruka Haru Hara there's crazy
hyperactive pink haired girls the source
of all the chaos in the series and when
she's not running people over with her
Vespa or repeatedly cracking heads open
with a bass guitar she seems to enjoy
dressing up some various people and
inappropriately touching little wall for
[ __ ] sake
there's also another character called
commander a morale that gets introduced
later in the series this person works
for a men in black type organization who
seems our past ties of Haruko as you can
see the most distinctive thing about
this character is those I brought those
eyebrows eyebrows eyebrows
eyebrows now while some people find
craziest in this show absolutely
hilarious
it may also throw some people off with
the absolute randomness the plot and
honestly I can't blame them even if
there is the main draw of this anime if
you didn't get an idea of what the show
is like for my plot description follow
the story is written by some EDD kid on
a sugar rush who has the attention span
of a goldfish it's crazy it's funny it's
bizarre and it makes absolutely no
[ __ ] sense yes yes I know the whole
show is actually a coming-of-age story
about one boy's journey through his
adolescent mind strung together behind a
fake head of craziness but seriously
even after watching it several times I
can't help but things myself what the
[ __ ] did I just watch so what do you
think I don't know son oh good
graphically not like curry powder
aphrodisiac licked off my desk
ah it's this kind of cool equally new
modality no no I mean like um this is
what you call talking [ __ ] a no utilizes
the right brain and left brains distinct
thought process is to open up an
interdimensional channel capable of
pulling things through wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what now with all this ranting about how
ran in the show is may sound like I'm
trying to be negative about it but I'm
only doing so because it's absolutely
impossible to describe the series
without going into how random is so this
doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad
thing and while it is the biggest draw
for the show the randomness isn't the
only thing he's got going for it
animation in this series bloody and
presip staleys but he also gets its fair
share of randomness every episode has a
few scenes with really unique all-stars
and it seems like the director was just
experimenting with different stuff at
times which resulted in some really cool
irken scenes sometimes the anime went to
manga style animation sometimes you've
got extra wacky colorful animation
sometimes you go intentionally crappy
gonzo animations sometimes you've got
[ __ ] South Park yes [ __ ] South
Park one part that actually has to be
mentioned is the soundtrack the
soundtrack consists of alternative rock
music done by a little-known group with
the pillows and it's honestly one of the
best sound recovered in anime period the
band's sound like a Japanese version of
The Pixies mix with voices and the music
fits with ever seen so perfectly that I
always felt like I was watching a bunch
of bizarre music videos that have been
strung together to form something
resembling a plot which is bloody
impressive considering the utter
randomness of some of the scenes this
cave the anime really unique
almost as if you're watching one giant
MV and honestly was the thing I like
most about series now I can talk an all
day about how good the superficial
things of the show are but the most
important thing is did I like it
well yeah I did kinda but definitely not
as much as some people do and I'm not
exactly sure why the show also uses the
rule of Korea stablished my samurai
champloo review and I go am it the show
is really cool but for some reason I
never got that feeling of oMG WTF epic
win roflcopter vbq sauce porn ish that
some people go of this show being the
best thing ever since sliced bread the
thing that left me the best impression
was the way the awesome soundtrack
played with the scenes and not the
quote-unquote hilarity that everyone
seems to be fawning over this show for
even if it did have some amazing
animation some kickass action scenes
he's really the one it's the real pirate
king yeah overall even though I did like
this anime I don't think I fully got it
or maybe I just didn't click with me as
a whole I find it funny but not
hilarious good but not great cool but
not sub-zero cool having said that I
definitely think you should check it out
because everyone can have a different
experience this anime some people get it
some people think it's a piece of [ __ ]
and some people think it's just met
there's no way to tell so no matter what
I or any other reviewers says about it I
recommend you go watch it
you mentioned end up loving it if not
for it's brilliant soundtrack or is just
complete randomness hmm
randomness randomness oh thank god I
give the show an AIDS
I'm just
suppose
ah